so now we know who's in the World Cup
final but we already know who won it
adidas Germany an adidas sponsored team
since 1954 we'll line up in Rio against
Argentina another adidas team captained
by Lionel Messi the jewel in adidas is
crowned and everyone will be kicking at
adidas ball every four years sports
apparel companies have to place their
bets on the World Cup they pay to get
their logos on players shirts and shoes
and then they hope for a win together
Nike and Adidas pull in about 70% of
global soccer revenue and between them
they've carved up the most competitive
national teams and most of the
tournament's stars this year adidas
focused its marketing campaign almost
entirely on the extraordinary left foot
of Lionel Messi Nike bet on Cristiano
Ronaldo who couldn't drag Portugal out
of the group round Nikes Brazil has now
shamed itself before history and Nike
sponsors the Netherlands always a
bridesmaid but this isn't soccer it's
marketing not just team against team but
strategy against strategy adidas
sponsors FIFA and with it the entire
World Cup it bought the right to make
the brazuca the ball you've now been
watching for a month Macke picks
superstars then puts them all together
in commercials that will look like the
World Cup problem is now they're all
gone
Ronaldo Neymar Rooney all home now some
in agony some in shame
what makes sports marketing risky is
what makes sports beautiful drama
happens Germany and Argentina will play
a historic great game but no matter who
wins the game and the whole Cup will be
great for Adidas
you